Wait.
What am I doing sitting inside scrolling
Facebook Marketplace on a beautiful day
like today? I should clearly be outside
browsing Facebook Marketplace.
Wait.
No way.
Isn't she beautiful?
This
is the Taylor 349 frozen carbonated
beverage freezer. She features four
7-quart freezing cylinders cooled by
twin compressors rated at 14,000
BTU per hour with microprocessor control
for your beverage preparation needs. Of
course,
I didn't buy this thing to drink from
it.
>> YOU'RE NOT?
>> NO, WITH ALL THAT REFINED sugar at my
age? No, I'm going to use it to COOL
THIS PC.
>> [screaming]
>> NO, WAIT. NO, HEAR ME OUT. HEAR ME OUT.
OKAY. OKAY.
>> Why not both?
>> Holy sh- It's going back in. Oh my god,
we didn't insulate any of this. This has
never been done before to my knowledge.
Oh, we we got to power it down. We got
to power it down. Maybe there's a reason
nobody's ever done this before.
>> It's not going to be that easy. This
thing's been sitting for like 10 years,
still full of syrup, there's leaks
everywhere, and it's supposed to be
running under pressure.
>> Like high pressure?
>> Probably.
>> No worries.
I got a guy.
And with a bit of his help, I believe we
are going to be able to not only cool
our PC with slushy, but also dispense
slushy from the PC cooling loop for
gaming consumption. I've also got a guy
who can do the segway to our sponsor.
>> [laughter]
>> Squarespace. They make it easy for you
to build the ideal website to go with
your brand or business. Create something
custom with their design intelligence
tool using our link down below.
>> What are we going to do with this thing?
Does it come with syrup at least?
>> we uh we got a bunch.
>> The first thing we're going to have to
do is some cleaning.
>> It looks like the previous owner left us
some juice.
>> I think we might have to replace the
front panel with some kind of manifold.
Did it screw off though?
>> Well, let's take a look. Okay.
>> Okay, only lines you can drink from
this.
>> Oh good god.
>> Oh my. There's an air conditioner in the
bottom there. Oh. So we're feeding in
syrup and CO2. It mixes in here.
>> And then it drains out into down here.
So this is both simple and incredibly
complicated. I think we're going to read
a manual or two.
>> Okay. While Justin spends the next
couple of weeks cleaning and doing some
minor repairs, here's how this thing is
meant to work, at least as I understand
it. We get a steady stream of water,
CO2, and syrup all into these hoppers up
here to get mixed up and shoved down
into the little freezing tubes down
here, where basically they'll just spin
around over and over again. Ice forms on
the walls and you use that to make your
slushy, your cool your PC, or whatever.
>> She may not look like much, but she is
fully operational now. So we've had
people actually drink slush from this
machine.
>> We have, yes.
>> And they didn't die.
>> That's terrific. Now it's time to end
the theorizing and actually get to work
building a loop into this thing. Justin
had a really good idea for how to get
the fluid out of the slushy cylinders.
So speed hole. Very nice.
>> Yep, tapped out a G1/4 fitting, standard
PC cooling fitting.
>> Out she goes.
>> And so we just can use the standard,
well, the pressure inside the cylinder
plus the auger, the spiral auger, and
>> That's it.
>> The other end?
A little more complicated. We dug this
insulation off one of the cylinders
looking for an easy way to get the
return coolant line from the PC back
into the cylinder. And what we
discovered was it's actually double
layered and the refrigerant sits in
between the walls for maximum slushy
cooling.
Which leaves us with where?
>> We thought about going into these
hoppers. That's where the CO2, the
water, and the syrup all mix.
>> Right.
>> But they're under pressure and we don't
really want to screw with a pressure
vessel.
>> Right.
>> What about second speed hole?
>> Brilliant.
>> Now comes the part where we go
completely off script and Justin and I
actually execute the plan or maybe
execute this slushy machine.
>> Let's Let's [laughter] hope not.
>> Let's really hope not. Even though it
was a Facebook Marketplace find, it
wasn't that cheap. This actually gives
us a really good look at why we weren't
able to go into the back of the
cylinder, either. You can see that
between all the moving parts in here and
the double wall,
there's just no way to get into it. Want
to show me how to put the augers
together?
>> So literally it's just that and then one
goes on this side here.
>> Okay, perfect. I got it.
>> Is it Are they all the same?
>> They should be.
>> Getting this thing back up and running
then, I mean, was it pretty
straightforward? How's access to
replacement parts, manuals, software?
>> It's a Taylor.
>> Oh, the McDonald's ice cream machine
maker.
>> Yeah, the the infamous ones.
>> So if we break anything,
>> Oh yeah, we're screwed.
>> Cool.
>> So if you look at the back, it's keyed.
>> Oh yeah, I see that. Oh, genius. Hey,
all right.
>> Just like that?
>> Just like that.
With those installed, WE JUST NEED THE
PIPE.
>> [laughter]
>> OKAY, UH IS THAT SUPPOSED TO HAPPEN?
What just happened?
>> Yes, so that's basically just a
retaining pin for this so you can't pull
it out.
>> Got it and I had it upside down.
So does that mean if I went to the local
7-Eleven, I
>> steal one.
>> I could just pull that pin?
>> 100% yep.
>> Basically, this just compresses the
spring, lifts up this dual gasketed sort
of plunger here, and then opens up ah
right there. This hole where this part
of the plate mushes the slushy through.
Okay, but there is one important
question, gentlemen. Slushy,
slurpy, or squishy?
>> Well, slurpy's trademarked.
>> So is Icee.
>> Oh. There is one more thing. This center
scraper piece has got to go all right
there. And what does this bad boy do? It
just helps clear the slushy out of the
center of the auger. Just keeps things
moving.
>> I have discovered a clever anti-theft
measure.
>> Oh, so you can't steal the retaining pin
unless you also steal all of these nuts.
>> Yeah.
It'll slowly down a little bit.
>> Steal these nuts?
These bad boys sit kind of here in order
to reduce wear and tear. Yeah, but we
actually installed them on this side.
And then oh,
don't forget your gaskets. Now,
long-time viewers of the channel may
remember I've actually done a video
cooling a PC with a fridge before. It
didn't work. So, why would we think that
the outcome here would be different? I
mean, this is essentially just a
beverage fridge. Well, yes, but also no.
See, this is a commercial grade beverage
fridge. It is designed to be operated
24/7 in demanding environments and maybe
more importantly, it is designed to get
those beverages ready fast. [snorts]
So, it has mondo excess cooling capacity
compared to how relatively little work
it normally needs to do, which is just
keep this cold, cool down any additional
syrup and water that gets
>> [snorts]
>> out into the cylinder. To be clear, a
constant heat load is not something this
is designed for and not something I
would actually recommend for long-term
use, but
at least for temporary purposes, it
should be able to comfortably handle the
heat load of both our PC
and our frozen beverages. Let's build
that PC.
And it's done.
Sort of.
If we want to use slushy to cool our
components, we're probably going to need
a water cooling loop. Now, our original
plan was to use this
gorgeous piece of copper that Justin
made up using a combination of 3D
scanning the card and also some of his
own innovations. The idea here was that
because our coolant is going to be so
cold, we don't have to worry as much
about having a dense fin array to
maximize heat transfer. We're more
concerned with creating a design that is
really low restriction so that we can
get like slush through it rather than
liquid water. Well, it turns out
that with the right pump, you can
actually force the slush through a
regular commercial block even with an
impingement plate installed in it. This
is a peristaltic
medical pump. Oh, and I totally see how
it works. It's got a motor on the back
just like any good pump would, but
instead of an impeller that's designed
to circulate fluid, it's got these three
rollers that actually squish and
compress a tube inside to force fluid in
one side and out the other. Kind of like
your digestive tract. So, we could pump
poop if we really wanted to.
>> Uh, yeah, okay.
>> What the hell did I just walk in on?
>> Poop pumping. Let's take a short break
from building though. I heard you have
an important decision for me to make.
Yes, what flavor?
>> [gasps and sighs]
>> Oh, what are my options?
>> So, we got lemon-lime,
cranberry cocktail,
>> Ooh.
>> or craft cola.
>> This is going to sound crazy, but I
actually want to pick based ON COLOR.
>> OH MY GOODNESS.
>> YEAH.
>> OH.
>> Every restaurant employee knows how
crappy these things are to deal with,
both lifting them and then breaking the
boxes down later. If you work at a
restaurant, you know. So, yeah, this
one's transparent. Uh
>> Oh, no, forget it.
>> Well, here's the thing. I bought some
food coloring
so we can just dump it into the hopper.
>> Okay. Okay, what what color is the
cranberry cocktail though?
>> Pop it open. Let's see.
>> Made from Ocean Spray cranberries, you
say? Ooh, red.
>> like a deep red.
>> Everyone knows red is performance. Let's
go cranberry cocktail.
>> Okay. Ooh, but I like the flavor of
lemon-lime better. This is a hard
decision. Well, we do have two barrels.
We can do both.
>> Yes.
>> Can we put some yellow dye in the lemon
lime and then we'll go red on the
cranberry cocktail?
>> Yeah, we can do that.
>> Let's do it.
>> The bar I worked at kindly provided
these for us.
>> Oh.
>> Shout out Billy Paul at Fox and Hound's
cub.
>> Shout out.
>> goat.
>> Okay, so they're going to have a cap on
them which we got to pop off.
>> Can we just be more honest though?
I don't want any caps in our
relationship, sorry.
You got this. I believe.
>> Come here, you bastard.
>> And then which one goes on?
>> Uh it's going to be the green one.
However, I just had a thought we should
probably put a hose clamp or two on
these sides.
>> Now all we got to do is
>> face shields.
>> Do we really need these?
>> Yeah, safe and sorry.
>> Wait, did you say safe and sorry?
>> You can be both.
>> This is where we turn on the CO2 gas.
>> Yes, correct.
>> Fun fact,
I did not actually realize that slushies
are carbonated.
>> Yeah, duh duh duh.
>> Like how are they carbonated? They they
they're tumbling around. But I guess
they're in a sealed environment, so
>> Depends on the country, too.
>> It depends on the country.
>> Apparently, whoop, in the states
apparently it's not actually
carbonated, but in Canada it is.
>> Weird. I could never tell anyway. It
didn't seem carbonated.
>> No. And in this case it's actually doing
double duties and that's actually what's
powering our syrup pumps.
>> Oh.
>> These aren't electrically driven. It's
they run off of CO2.
>> Oh, wicked smart. Okay.
>> Yeah, do it.
>> Oh god.
>> Now we'll fire on the machine.
>> This is my jam.
>> Safety timeout.
>> Any key aborts?
>> There's some errors. It's fine.
>> We legitimately did have some Taylor
issues. Like we can't get into any of
the configuration panels because we
don't know the password. So, yeah.
>> Defaults.
>> So, first things first, now that
everything's going, we're going to hit
prime.
>> Nice.
>> Oh oh it's going it's going.
Oh you can you can see the green.
You can see the red.
>> Oh buddy.
>> All right, and because it wasn't flowing
as good as it should have been, I think
we should just drain a little bit out so
that way we get more concentrate syrup
through.
I was actually going to say we can try
it now and see if the flavors are like
>> Oh, it's totally fine. With it primed,
what do we do next?
>> Auto.
>> Oh, can I do it?
>> Hit the other one. It's not ready yet.
>> Nice.
>> So now just to make sure that everything
is actually cooling, we can go into the
menu.
>> Yeah.
>> And we can get to
>> Order a hot dog.
>> That would be so sweet.
>> That alarm
Is that a good alarm?
>> That's the everything's okay alarm.
>> Right. Can we turn it off?
>> For 5 minutes at a time.
>> And just yeah, cuz we can't get into it.
It just
>> Yeah.
>> Cool.
>> So we got our barrel temperatures here
and as we can see temperatures are
starting to drop.
>> Oh, they're dropping.
>> And they they drop quick.
>> I mean, they would. That's a giant
compressor for just
cooling a couple
gallons of fluid.
>> Like it's about 20 minutes to get the
slush. Like it's pretty quick.
>> Wow. All right.
>> That gives me and Jordan 20 minutes to
be ready.
>> We got this.
>> You know, I don't think there's been a
project in recent memory that they
thought I'm more crazy for starting than
this one. It took us a year to get to
this point with all the like fighting
with this thing being broken and
learning how to use it and
figuring out how to actually get coolant
pumped through it.
>> Just gluing it was months.
>> Think about it though. We now have as a
company a working slushy machine.
For the low low cost of like syrup we
can have slushies.
>> Hey Justin, you're bleeding.
>> We are. Trying to figure out where
though.
>> Ah, right there.
>> Ah, dang. It's the one I did.
>> There we go.
>> Solid.
>> Oh, we're getting close. We almost have
slush.
>> Woah, buddy.
>> However, one thing I did notice on this
machine for whatever reason, yeah, this
barrel cools down way faster than this
one.
>> It's possible that the refrigerant is in
series. It wouldn't normally matter
because for the most part they're just
doing maintenance. They're not actually
pulling down I mean more than what once
a day?
>> Yeah, that's that's a good point
actually cuz yeah it's still steadily
dropping.
>> If you ever happen to find yourself
water blocking or just taking off your
cooler for maintenance, it's a great
time to add PTM 7950 to your GPU die
available at lttstore.com. With that in
mind, not all thermal interface
materials are ideal for all applications
and for sub-zero PTM is not necessarily
the best.
>> We've gone with a more standard thermal
paste.
>> Number two's frozen that's not a good
way to say nope.
>> [laughter]
>> Poop pumping. The second one's frozen
we're going to do some quality control.
>> Heck yeah.
>> That's good.
>> Now a question for you Yordan.
>> Yes sir.
>> Do we need to use any special kind of
tubing in the loop or anything like a
food safe tubing or
>> We have got food safe tubing.
>> Nice. All right. Power for our GPU and
then I mean
that's basically
>> That's it. We got to plumb that in and
the pump.
>> Right. Okay, let's get the pump in here.
In an effort to maintain as much food
safety as we can, we're going to be
using brand new fittings
and then because we don't actually have
any that are exactly the right inner
diameter and outer diameter, we're not
going to be using the outer collars.
We're just going to
put them on like that
and then use these worm drives in order
to seal them up.
>> Allegedly number one's done. I'm
actually going to try taking it out of
our little spout here and just see how
it goes.
It is coming out on its own not very
fast. That is way too thick.
>> Yeah, I mean we'll get some heat into it
and it'll change very quickly but
>> Well, I just actually I was trying to
get more out and all thick and all rich
in the mixture. So underneath the the
catch tray, there's four mixture screws
down here and this is what controls your
water to syrup mixture. So all I did was
just give it a quarter turn just to give
it a bit more syrup and that should
allow the
the slush mix to be more slushy. That's
how we used this operator's manual to
fix that.
>> Did we steal this?
>> No comment.
>> Wait, where's our pump going? I forgot
about that.
>> It can be outside.
>> Brilliant. Okay, so here's what we're
going to do then.
I've got the outlet of my GPU block
going into the inlet of my CPU block.
>> Okay.
>> I'm going to take out these two PCI
covers and the hoses just go like this.
And then
>> [clears throat]
>> Tada!
>> And then where are we putting the pump?
Was the plan to power the pump off of
the PC?
>> No.
>> Oh, okay, perfect. Then it
>> more power than that.
>> Right. How long does this need to be now
then?
>> That might be a little long.
Let's get closer to the machine.
>> That makes sense. One, two, three, oh.
Yeah, that was bound to happen.
>> OKAY. NO WAY! OKAY, this is amazing.
The ergonomics of this are incredible.
So, I just put my PC right here.
I'm gaming. I got Slurpee. I got
cooling.
>> I mean, we could turn it around. You
could sit it right there and you could
reach over.
>> Holy crap.
>> So, I think we should do a return on
that side.
>> Return on this side? Okay. It's
happening. Guys, it's been a year in the
making since I found this stupid thing
on Facebook. Is there a reason that you
put these long extensions on here? Does
that just help with the ergonomics of
this?
>> Yeah, it's hard to clear the handle that
way.
>> Got it. Got it. That makes sense.
You guys aren't going to know this, but
back-to-back I got to shoot steam-cooled
steam machine and slushy-cooled PC.
Like, this is so cool. Where do you want
the pump? Does that need to Which side
does it need to be on?
>> Uh this side is the inlet. It's
dependent on motor direction and we can
reverse direction of the motor.
>> Okay. Pump right here?
Put it front and center?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. There to there?
>> Yes. There to out.
>> Yeah. Wait, do we have other fittings
for this?
>> No, that works.
>> Uh
I really don't think it does.
>> It did. The heck?
>> Do we have a coupler?
>> Coupler, I hardly know her. I'll be
right back with a coupler.
>> You know, you could go easy on the taste
test there, Justin.
>> No, I'm trying to keep the mixture
consistent cuz if we let it freeze too
long, it doesn't move properly.
>> Oh, okay. So, that's something that we
just have to kind of fine-tune the syrup
water ratio.
>> Yeah, and we don't have the
refractometer to do it correctly.
>> Sorry, we need a what now to do it
correctly?
>> Uh refractometer.
>> And what you just pointed at the thing
or what?
>> No, you pour the like the syrup water
mixture into it and then it'll tell you
how much sugar level is in the syrup mix
and then you adjust based on that.
>> What's a refractometer run you?
>> No idea.
It's a good question.
>> Okay, here we go.
Closing up the last fitting. Now, how
does a peristaltic pump get primed?
>> Uh that's the best part. You just turn
it on.
>> Really? It it just moves air? Like it's
it's it like seals against the thing to
just
>> Correct.
>> Wow.
>> Yeah, there's
>> Right, cuz otherwise how could you fart?
>> Exactly.
>> Dude,
we are so freaking close.
>> Okay.
>> Are we ready?
>> So, let's do one more purge.
>> One more purge. Okay, she flows?
>> Yeah, she's looking good. Okay.
Okay, so yeah, you're going to crack
that one.
Boom.
You're going to crack that one. A boom.
And you're going to hit the power
button.
>> A boom.
Holy holy crap. Holy crap. It's going
BACK IN.
THAT PUMP freaking pumps.
>> Does it Does it dispense?
>> This thing freaking goes. Holy
crap. Let's power on the system. We're
going to get Oh my god, we didn't
insulate any of this.
>> No, if we were going to 24/7 this, we've
actually done a number of guides for how
to condensation proof your hardware. I
don't have time to talk about that right
now. Whatever, check out one of the
videos with play. Where is the damn
power Oh, here it
>> I have no idea.
>> We found it.
Okay, let's do this. Let's get all this
clear. We've got post, ladies and
gentlemen. You're seeing it right here.
World's first slushy cooled gaming
system. Holy
This has never been done before to my
knowledge. Holy sh
What just happened? The pump stopped.
Did it die already? Did it overheat?
It's not hot. Buddy, you good?
>> we done?
>> Holy it's solid ice.
Justin, it's solid ice.
>> Is it?
>> Dude, this frozen in the block.
Yeah, turn it off. Turn it off cuz we'll
definitely overload it. Okay, we we got
power down. We got to power it down.
Maybe there's a reason nobody's ever
done this before. We need to put in some
heat. Okay, okay. So, we got that going.
We got What can I do on the CPU?
Cinebench. It's frozen freaking solid,
dude. Okay, so we apparently do not have
our mixture quite [music] right. Did the
system just crash? Oh god. I got the
pump back on.
Is it even moving anything though?
>> Oh, it is. It's moving just a tiny bit.
>> moving a little bit.
>> Okay, but
I'm not getting an output from the GPU
right now. Here, let's power down
and power back up. Our poor GPU block is
like frosting over. Yeah, okay. That's
fine. That's fine.
Okay, we're we're back.
Screw it. We're going straight to Black
Myth: Wukong. We're going straight to
gaming, boys. She's definitely a little
thick. That may be the problem.
Delicious though.
Okay, it's HW info. GPU temp
3.5°
casually. My CPU is sitting at around
12°. Okay, we're launching Black Myth:
Wukong.
Got to refresh my body. Is it moving?
Yep.
Oh, it was.
>> We got flow.
>> We got flow?
>> There were chunks of ice moving in the
CPU block. I've got an empty hose here
now.
>> Heck yeah. CPU's still at 28°, so we're
still good on that. Retrying launching
the game.
>> I am about to be
>> the first man to game on a slushy cooled
the
There she goes. she's moving. She's
moving. CPU's dropped to 45, 44.
Hey Blackmyth, you can launch anytime
now. Come on, buddy. Come on. Come on.
Oh, it's frozen in here. Right here,
Jordan.
CPU's at 99.5. Shader compilation in
progress. Oh, she's moving. She's
moving.
We've got ice in the CPU block. We got
movement. I don't know if I'm ready to
call this a success, but the system
hasn't crashed or died yet. Yeah, it's
definitely just too thick.
Like you can see, even though I haven't
drank that much, it's like it's snow
already.
Um boys,
the coolant may be about to boil in that
CPU block. Okay, initial setup. Here we
go, here we go, here we go. Wait, are we
are we circulating?
>> Maybe.
>> We are. Holy crap. Frame cap backs,
whatever whatever we up for temps. Oh,
what Why do I NOT SEE TEMPS? OKAY, let's
go. Confirm. Here we go, here we go,
here we go.
Blackmyth: Wukong, cooled by slushy.
Holy crap, it's going. Guys, IT'S GOING.
>> IT'S WORKING! [screaming]
>> HERE WE ARE.
BLACKMYTH: WUKONG, casual 200 FPS.
I'mma be honest with you, I have no idea
what settings we're running at. Feels
like there might be some frame gen
involved. DLSS, oh yeah, frame gen's on.
Let's turn that off.
Uh blah blah blah, cinematic.
>> [music]
>> We're at 4K, about 75 85 FPS. Hold on.
What are my temps though? CPU is sitting
at 33 33° C.
Hold on, one sec.
OH, YEAH.
GPU, 25°.
SEE, the real question this video is
going to raise is, why wouldn't [music]
everybody do this now? It's just so
convenient. I don't think there's much
more to say other than
I'm late for a meeting,
and I promised them if they gave me an
extra 20 minutes, I would bring them all
slushies. So, let's get some slushies
together and let's meet with you guys
about our sponsor.
>> Squarespace. It's the all-in-one website
platform that helps with everything from
building a personalized site for your
business all the way to opening an
online store. Create something unique to
your brand with their design
intelligence tool. All you need to do is
answer a couple of quick questions, pick
a general vibe, and you have a custom
template. If you want to sell something
from your website, Squarespace can help
with payment processing as well. It
works with major payment methods like
Apple Pay, credit, debit, and payment
plans. They'll even assist with SEO
tools, making sure that your website
finds the right audience when people
search for you online. There are
millions of URLs to choose from to help
with this, too. Track your performance,
adjust on the fly, and keep growing your
business. Hey, we've even used
Squarespace here at LMG. Start building
your website today and receive 10% off
your first purchase by visiting
squarespace.com/ltt.
>> If you guys enjoyed this video and you
love these kinds of shenanigans, don't
miss the steam-cooled steam machine.
Very similar energy.
Ah.
>> [laughter]
>> Hoot pumping.